before i begin i feel it is necessary to
point out that the news arm of the bbc
has yet to retract apologize or
otherwise address the deeply transphobic
reporting it has engaged in in the last
few months in a pinned comment down
below you'll find my original video on
the topic several videos from the
youtuber sean who has been ongoing in
his pursuit of trying to get the bbc to
own up to what they have done and also a
video from laura kate dale showing the
protests that have taken place outside
of the bbc offices while i don't feel
any of the people behind doctor who are
in any way responsible for this i cannot
in good conscience talk about a bbc
owned property without mentioning this
first until such time as it is properly
redressed thank you
but how do you know she's a witch
what she turned me into a note a newt
i got better
[Music]
take two doctor reviews continue and we
have reached
the witch finders which
i really didn't know
what even to expect out of this one
here's the thing this is probably the
episode i remember
the least in terms of leaving an overall
impression pretty much every other
episode whether details have faded or
not left me with an overall pressure
impression somewhere along the line
whether it be
i really like that
something was throwing me off
disappointment something which finder is
thinking back and i'm like
i don't remember what i thought about
this one and i didn't go back and check
my old review so i came in and just be
like
i think i know what some of the
complaints have been about this over
time but i really don't remember this
thing at all
having not watched it
it's actually pretty good
for about three quarters of the run time
before it completely
just botches things that well i say
completely it doesn't completely botch
you're completely botching it would be
completely undermining what it had done
up to that point and it doesn't do that
but it does really go off the rails at
the very end
prior to that it's uh it's all right
though i mean like there's weird little
things there's like the fact that the
doctor and the companions they rock up
on this village and yes they're not
they're not where they expected to be
they expected to be there for the
coronation of elizabeth the first but
the thing is like they're just decked
out in their modern clothes
and yeah
that would happen sometimes but usually
either
it would get noted by people pretty
quickly they would be dressed in
something that was uh close enough that
people just kind of gave a little looker
like ah whatever or they would actually
dress appropriately for the time that
was a bit more of a healthy thing than
anything else
however here they just show up
and nobody brings it up none of the
companions ask if they should have
gotten changed and nobody brings it up
i'd say for about 10 minutes
it doesn't really matter it's just weird
it's an odd choice
but i mean the main thing this is
focusing on is
well just the
insane
tragedy and miscarriage of anything even
close to justice
that
which trials and hysteria was
and delving into
you know the idea that a lot of people's
personal hurt or fear
or biases or agendas were driving
the accusations of witchcraft
and we see that through uh becca uh
savage who is sort of the
controlling interest in this town that
um actually i found this to be an
interesting point when graham's like you
know i've taken like the witch tour
uh this place never came up and if that
many people have been killed there we
really should have known about that
that's actually that's not a bad moment
because in a bit of dialogue that
actually feels revealing a little bit
about his character like that's the kind
of thing he does for fun it also reveals
to us that this is an aberration we are
not stepping into a well-established
well-known witch hysteria this is
something that shouldn't be going on so
that's actually a nicely integrated bit
of exposition unlike say when becca
ravages like 35 witches
[Music]
which is just
just comes out of nowhere and is jammed
in there and is
clunkily expository so like within a few
minutes of each other we have examples
of well-executed expository dialogue
because it also addresses a an aspect of
character and just really clunky
expository dialogue that is there for no
reason other than to convey information
but sort of uh but sort of bringing up
how uh i feel like that actually is a
little bit revealing about graham's
character and what he does in his off
time i also really like that yaz is the
one who goes and talks to willa who is
the girl whose uh grandmother was just
drowned
the show is coming back intermittently
on this whole thing of
you know she wants to talk to people and
get a better sense of what's going on
and that is something that isn't
necessarily being attributed to her
police training but it has been tied to
that and her sort of like i got to go in
and talk to people to try and sort
things out and that fits with her role
as being a part of the police and we
also
get some hints as to aspects of her
background that we will find more about
later
because she talks about like being
really miserable as a teenager really
miserable in school every day i'd wake
up feeling this
dread how did you get rid of it
i didn't
i just took it
and because of stuff we know later we
know she was actually a runaway at one
point as a teenager so
knowing
stuff that happens later i'm what i'm
finding is because one of the criticisms
i've seen about chibnall's era is that
um the characters aren't particularly
well-formed or characterized aspects of
them aren't consistent and sometimes
that's true i've kind of brought it up
that ryan's dyspraxia is very
it comes and it goes and like times
where you expect it to come up it
doesn't and then the times that it does
come up we get
it gets reminded in very weird ways so
like some things are inconsistent but
some other things i feel like
i i feel like the characterization is
done
in
simultaneously
often offhanded and kind of subtle ways
and then in very clunky ways and if
you're yo-yoing back and forth between
those you know kind of comparing
something like me
noticing the pattern of yaz always being
like let me talk to them let me talk to
her and noticing that as a pattern of
behavior for her
and you know feeling like that's a good
relatively subtle bit of
characterization
but then we tend to have the classic hey
what are you feeling right now seen
between the companions where it's very
clunky and
i can see where it would throw people
off because
the the times that it's clunky really
jump out at you and you think well
that's what characterization is in this
and if that's all you're looking for and
you're not looking for characterization
in the smaller moments you could miss
what's there now it's still a problem
that it's going back and forth between
these two not the same approach at all
ways of characterizing these people but
like there are through lines here and
stuff that does get paid off or fleshed
out later on and it's nice to see
a random line that i just like i i
really like
that when um becca starts quoting uh the
bible and like you know firing rip some
old testament stuff that i really like
the doctor's line in the old testament
there's a twist in the sequel that's
just a good line this is a good way of
delivering that because like it's
it is one of those moments that in many
many many pieces of media it comes off
as deeply condescending um you know this
this idea that
um the enlightened person who doesn't
believe the religious text
knows it better than the than the person
who claims to be a believer like it can
come off as really condescending to the
idea of faith sometimes but it doesn't
hear largely just because of the way
it's wording there's a twist in the
sequel like that's
that's a great way to put it i gotta
love that now i should probably get to
um king james alan [ __ ] there's the
way he's written which isn't great but
then there's the way he's played
which is also i'd rather like the drama
so
he's written
uh again sort of
especially uh in his conversation with
ryan
kind of reciting his own wikipedia entry
i was raised by regents
one was assassinated one died in battle
and another
died in suspicious circumstances
and it's
not great
writing it's not great exposition it's
not great dialogue
but man alan [ __ ] is having so much
fun he is relishing every moment of this
and i'm not gonna say it fixes the
dialogue but it really made me care way
less than if it had been a really flat
boring performance but alan [ __ ] is
not boring i have a lot of fun watching
him he looks like he's having a lot of
fun and again while that doesn't fix
problems with the with the script or
with the dialogue
it makes him go down a heck of a lot
easier and it makes me care way less
and i feel like he does a decent amount
of again
fairly subtle things like you don't kind
of realize until the very end that he
was kind of flirting with ryan along the
way in this whole thing and you think
back on it it was pretty much right from
the instant he saw ryan and it's kind of
like oh
and what is your field of expertise is
my nubian prince
uh
okay
and again he's just having so much fun
and he i'm not gonna say he's he saves
the episode or is like the highlight of
the episode i will say he saves this uh
interpretation of king james saves him
as a character absolutely and actually
jody whitaker gets a little bit of the
same thing when she's facing down
against um king james after she's been
you know kind of tied up you wear it
like a hero
even though you're killing
and scapegoating and stirring up hate
and you wonder why the darkness comes
back at you
and this the sort of speech he gives to
him is not
amazing but she does deliver it really
well and there is a forcefulness
and a way that she is just trying to get
him to listen and the way she is going
about just delivering those lines is
actually really good so uh kind of like
with ally coming it's also an instance
of all right the script is
but she's doing a really good job at
selling it especially in that moment
now we've got
like i said the overall sort of thematic
things to deal with of
you know which scares and all of the
baggage that comes with that um i've
seen some people really get hung up on
the fact that the doctor is not accused
of being a witch or that she's not
questioned as a woman a lot sooner i
think that's probably part of the reason
why the head of the town becca savage is
also a woman um so that it creates a
situation where like the people who live
here aren't completely unfamiliar with
the concept of a woman with some degree
of authority so i think that is again a
relatively subtle touch that has it make
more sense in this specific setting uh
it does get addressed briefly you know
where she says you know if i was a man
you'd all you'd all be listening to me
right now which eh
fair enough but you know just focusing
in on the way that the fear
whether it's fear of what's going to
happen to one's own soul like becca has
and she's going about trying to
save herself in a really twisted
frigging fashion whether it's that or
whether it's fear of being put on trial
like willa clearly has when she kind of
scrambles you know she's not completely
turning on the doctor but she is kind of
like finding something that will placate
james and becca and take their eye off
of her
and put it on the doctor it is there and
that is the kind of stuff that is
good to explore if you're going to do a
witch trial story and also i appreciate
the fact that
while the um
the aliens once we get the backstory of
what's going on the what the heck are
they called the morax god these names
this season they really stink
anyways you know with with the morax it
can be argued that once we have the
backstory that they are kind of the
inciting incident in a way or at least
they're half of it because we know that
becca kind of spiraled once she was
infected with this thing and she's been
trying to head it off and it drove her
uh into her worst behaviors and worse
tendencies but
she still made all those decisions
herself
this doesn't let
people off the hook because while this
specific incident and town
is fictionalized this kind of stuff did
happen and it was done by people and
people should not be let off the hook
for that and they're not thankfully
unfortunately
with about eight minutes left to go
we kill the human villain and suddenly
have to deal with mud monster aliens
this is where the whole thing derails
because the instant becca dies and is
taken over by the morax which again are
not really the villains and haven't been
up to that point which is good as i said
but now suddenly they are and this is
what we have to deal with and this has
nothing to do with the primary themes
that we've been dealing with about
misplaced um you know sort of
christian righteousness or the
fear-mongering or just the way that
neighbors sort of turn on each other all
that's out the window while we deal with
freaking mud monsters for the last eight
minutes and most of that eight minutes
is spent doing exposition because since
these things haven't been the focus
prior to now we have to spend most of
this time explaining what the hell is
even going on and how they got here and
how we stopped them and it's all
technobabble and it's a mess
it's rushed and it's boring and it is
something that i just cannot get
invested in in any way shape or form
because even though like the mud
creatures were established as being
there they weren't the problem they
weren't the threat they were a
complication they seem to be but
suddenly they're the main thing we're
having to deal with for the supposed
climax of the story and it just does
not
work
and it's a shame
it's a shame because
more was working than not you know i
pointed out you know some of the script
wasn't great you know these little bits
that little bits but like
it was being sold well it wasn't the
best product but it was being decently
sold largely by the performers alan
cummings as i said
really was relishing this and jodie
whitaker has some of her better
performance moments as the doctor
especially with that speech that she
gives uh you know trying to talk down
king james which again on paper is not
great but she sells it really well and
it's an interaction that i really like
and appreciate from her but
once the morax take over the story
and that's what the ending of this thing
becomes
this is just so detached
from the themes the threat
the concepts
the ideas like
it's just this is just nonsense
this is just a nonsense alien threat
defeated with technobabble
and it's it's it's a shame
i would actually say that this this
really would have benefited from being a
pure historical
this is another one
where we don't need a monster
this didn't need a monster
saranga conundrum didn't need a monster
42 didn't need a monster
now granted chibnall didn't write this
one specifically but he was the runner
and those other two that i cited were
written by him so there seems to be an
issue a little bit with chibno where
stories are being told
that not only don't need a monster they
would be better for the absence of one
this as a pure historical no alien
i think that could have been really good
instead it's just
almost good
which is a frustrating thing to take in
a couple of other last minute things
it's odd to me when like the doctor
scans willa uh and looks at her sonic
screwdriver you know to get readings
which i said like i appreciate that
that's kind of the main way the sonic
gets used these days uh and he goes huh
you know no this no that no magic and
i'm like wait a minute since when can
the
when can the sonic screwdriver detect
magic and if it can detect it is it
magic
is that what it would like it would have
been one thing if she'd like no
telepathic field or like something other
than that but just like oh no magic i'm
like
you can detect you have a magic detector
since when
since when does the sonic screwdriver
get loaded with a certain number of
charges of detect magic when did that
happen
i don't know that's a tiny thing but it
bugged me a little bit um i also noticed
a couple of references to the flat team
structure backing come on it's a very
flattering structure
another thing that i i it's nice to
notice here because i know
uh especially in series 12
where
uh it comes up most prominently in the
haunting of villa dia daddy
that's gonna be rebutted a bit and it's
kind of interesting to catch the earlier
references to what everyone likes to
think it is
knowing it'll get challenged later so
that was nice too so you know it's just
it's just a very mixed bag
the witch finders what do you think
about it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down the comments let's talk
about it patreon's what pays the bills
around here and we'll pay for
a new light for the lava lamp which is
why that's not currently on that's
probably going to be the case
um for
the couple of episodes uh so
apologies for that
it's weird for me to not have it have it
there either but
ah whatever uh but even if you can't
support me financially like share
subscribe also help me out and there's
links to other things that i do down in
the description there is merchandise i
have t-shirts i have books for sale i am
on twitch and tick tock and twitter and
all that is in the description
but uh don't worry too much about it
what i really want you to remember
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
you are loved
you are the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
hey end credits time which means i need
to shout out some patrons this time i'm
going to be shouting out robin moore
zubin lutfalla turok oliver b melinda
walters imudelki the oath the boy tt for
knobby lax the poodle zach paul idoln
tracy scrappet vincent paul bartolucci
angry casper toku b.l whovian adam rdl
taylor shane ross shaylee gourley and
brendan larose you want to hear me
mispronounce your name check out rewards
on the patreon
thanks for all your support
[Music]